How did we find the value for
x in x -4 = 7?
When solving an equation,
the goal is to get the variable on one
side of the equation alone
with a coefficient of one.
You are not done until your
equation is in this form.
With the equation of x- 4 = 7,
we can do this
by adding four to both
sides of the equation and
then we get x + 0 because
-4 + 4 = 0 = 7+4.
So why did we add four to
both sides of the equation?
Why can't we just add it to one side?
That's because an equation
is perfectly balanced.
We could think of equations as scales
that have to have the same value on
both sides.
If you perform an operation on one side
but not the other side of the equation,
the equation will be out of balance and
therefore it is no longer true.
So if I add four to one side of my
equation but not the other side,
my equation is no longer in balance.
I have to do the same thing to the other
side to rebalance the equation.
So, how did I decide on four to add?
It's because I'm trying to
get X by itself and -4+4 = 0.
We can check our work here
by substituting 11 in for
X in the original equation.
x-4=7 becomes 11-4=7.
11-4 is indeed equal to 7 so
we did it right.
Let's try another one.
Find x if x+12=16.
Enter your answer here.